[Music]  [Music]  cool  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hey  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  um  i wanna  try it out  [Music]  i wanna  try i wanna join  [Music]  um  [Music]  um  [Music]  uh  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  um  [Music]  me  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you